president Trump is now publicly
demanding stricter gun control in a
break with the NRA and fellow
Republicans the president met with
lawmakers at the white house yesterday
and told them he'd even support
bypassing due process to take guns from
the mentally ill Paula Reed is at the
White House with the surprising remarks
from the president Paula good morning
good morning the central theme of the
president's agenda was strengthening
background checks for folks trying to
purchase weapons he brought that up
about a dozen times in that meeting with
lawmakers but he says no matter what
action is actually taken he just wants
to quickly end the nonsense of mass
shootings
we have to act we can't wait and play
games
and nothing gets done president Trump
stunned lawmakers on both sides of the
aisle Wednesday with his overarching
demands for gun control trying to take
the Firearms first and then go to court
after vice president Mike Pence
suggested court procedures for removing
guns from dangerous people Trump caught
him and many in the room off guard by
seeming to dismiss due process I like
taking the guns earlier so you could do
exactly what you're saying but take the
guns first go through due process
president Trump also reiterated his
support for raising the age limit to
purchase some weapons it doesn't make
sense I have to wait till I'm 21 to get
a handgun but I can get this weapon at
18. I don't know so I was just curious
as to what you did in your bill
my reservation about it frankly is that
the vast majority of 18 19 and 20 year
olds in Pennsylvania who have a rifle or
a shotgun
they're not a threat to anyone typically
an ally of the NRA Mr Trump said he's
willing to act without the group's
support I think you underestimate the
power of the gun lobby they have great
power over you people
they have less power over me the
president did stop short of supporting a
ban on assault weapons but some are
skeptical that he will follow through on
his demand for Action I think it's just
as likely that the White House Personnel
will be up here in the next few days
doing the NRA's bidding but the
president certainly committed himself to
things that if he puts his full weight
behind it can get done
the NRA is calling the president's
proposal bad policy but the President
says if a bill reaches his desk he will
sign it although some critics note he
was equally bullish on DACA and nothing
was ever passed Alex Paula the president
tweeted again yesterday about his
attorney general calling Jeff sessions
disgraceful for asking the Inspector
General to look into the fisa process
what has been the reaction to that
latest Salvo over at the justice
department
well since the Attorney General recused
himself from the Russia investigation
the president has publicly criticized
his attorney general and the justice
department the Attorney General does not
tend to respond to this in any way and
this Dynamic has actually become
something that special counsel Robert
Mueller is looking into as part of his
inquiry into into obstruction of justice
but yesterday the Attorney General
really surprised a lot of us he pushed
back with a public statement sort of
suggesting that the president was
ignorant of the investigative process
and saying he will continue to serve as
attorney general with a dignity and
honor thanks Paula yeah there are
reports that he calls attorney general
Mr Magoo behind the scenes that's got to
be tough it's it's interesting to see
how this White House operates it is not
normal to have passive aggressive
competing statements they have phones
they can call each other publicly
unprecedented as many things are that's
a word we use a lot thank you very much
again Paulo